[Music]
today's air conditioning and
refrigeration systems essentially follow
the same principles that have been
around for about a hundred years if we
continue along today's path then that
sets us up for a future where air
conditioning can actually become one of
our single largest source of greenhouse
gas emissions later this century air
conditioners have become an inescapable
part of our cities they operate thanks
to refrigerants chemicals which when
released into the atmosphere are potent
greenhouse gases AC units also require
huge amounts of energy the u.s. uses
more electricity for cooling than Africa
does for everything as it becomes
affordable for millions more people the
problems that come with a/c will only
get worse which is why scientists around
the world are searching for solutions
[Music]
here at the National University of
Singapore professor Chua and his team
are completely rethinking air
conditioning to save energy
secondly to save our environment what we
have in the lab is next generation of
air conditioners where is actually
environmentally friendly
less energy-intensive it doesn't eject
you to the environment and doesn't need
the chemical refrigerant it's a water
based air conditioning it requires a one
liter order to operate for three hours
and you can use rain water power the
system but there's a limitation the end
needs to be dry
before you can carry out this process in
the efficient way and that's why there
are two separate stages in this AC first
it dries the air using membranes that
filter the moisture then the water
inside the unit evaporates taking heat
with it it's close to what most of us
experience every day sweating the system
uses 30% less energy than a traditional
air conditioner and is also expected to
be 30% Jebus crucially it uses no
refrigerant and although it's not
available yet the government is backing
this project betting that soon it could
be a breath of fresh air for Singapore
and Beyond across the other side of the
world one startup in California is
looking towards outer space to
revolutionize cooling and they're about
to test their breakthrough in the field
right now if we measure the temperature
of our surface it's around 48 degrees
Fahrenheit and the air temperature is 60
Fahrenheit we're not evaporating water
and we're not using any electricity you
can see we're in the middle of a field
and it is just a thin film coating that
enables this coiling effect and it does
this 24 hours a day seven days a week
sky coal systems is commercializing a
technology that harnesses the cold of
the sky and space to enable electricity
free cooling as implausible as that may
sound at first glance the way it works
is it takes advantage of a natural
phenomenon that allows a surface that's
looking up to the sky to essentially
send out some of its heat nearly
everything on earth gives off heat in
the form of infrared radiation sky calls
panels act like high-tech mirrors
reflecting some of that heat out to the
cold expanse of space allowing a surface
to dip below the temperature of the
surrounding air sky calls multi-layer
film means that it's now possible to
achieve evie during the day the panel's
could be added on to today's cooling
systems reducing their energy used by as
much as 20%
see energy we use for cooling is
expected to grow six-fold by the year
2050 and it's primarily gonna be driven
in warmer countries where air
conditioning is not prevalent today what
excites us about our technology is that
it represents a unique and easily
different way of handling the cooling
problem by taking use of a resource
that's always been there the fact that
space is cold it's almost like this has
been literally over our heads for
centuries millennia but it's something
we've not been able to use as a
technology with the demand for air
conditioning skyrocketing using water
and the cold outer space may turn out to
be the best bet we have for our warming
cities
[Music]
you
you